[Música]
el tribunal superior de londres dio la
razón a eeuu tras considerar que existen
las garantías suficientes para la
extradición del fundador de wikileaks
julian assange a eeuu un fallo del
pasado enero negó el traslado de assange
por riesgo de suicidio y la decisión
puede ser apelada por el equipo de
abogados de la activista
la primera visita oficial de olaf scholz
el flamante canciller alemán fue al
inicio hoy mantuvo una reunión con el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón donde
trataron los temas más álgidos del
momento en europa tenemos reporte desde
parís
eeuu y taiwán rechazaron la decisión de
nicaragua de romper las relaciones con
taipei mientras que china celebró el
restablecimiento de sus vínculos
diplomáticos
managua reconoció a china como un único
país
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en francés 24 0 blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos y
comenzamos el tribunal superior de
londres avaló la extradición del
fundador de wikileaks julian assange ya
eeuu la justicia consideró que
washington ofrece las garantías
suficientes para así proteger la salud
física y mental de la activista luego de
que en enero se negara su traslado por
riesgo de suicidio de concretarse la
extradición julian assange se
enfrentaría a cargos por espionaje y
conspiración en eeuu el fundador de
wikileaks fue detenido por la policía
británica en abril de 2019 después de
que el gobierno de ecuador pusiera fin
al asilo que le consiguió en 2012 y que
lo llevó a permanecer recluido en
embajada de ecuador en londres desde ese
año
cómo han podido aceptar una extradición
al país que planeó matar a jullian que
planeó matar a un editor por lo que
publicó esto ataca los fundamentos de la
libertad de prensa y de la democracia
lucharemos cada generación tiene una
batalla épica que luchar esta es la
nuestra porque julián representa los
fundamentos de lo que significa vivir en
una sociedad libre pero qué significa
tener libertad de prensa de lo que
significa para los periodistas hacer su
trabajo sin tener miedo de pasar el
resto de sus vidas en prisión
reino unido en cárcel la periodista 2
cambiamos ahora información porque como
es costumbre para un nuevo canciller
alemana el recién juramentado el af
charles acudió a parís para reunirse con
el presidente manuel macrón este último
tras el encuentro destacó en la
convergencia que tienen sus ideas
globales de la reunión fue una
oportunidad para tratar temas como la
lucha contra la pandemia y cambio
climático así como también los
conflictos de ucrania y rusia el boicot
diplomático a los juegos olímpicos de
invierno de beijing 2022 esta periodista
en varis natalia ruiz nos informó al
respecto veamos
así es muy buenas tardes pues olaf
scholz cumplió como manda digamos la
tradición que es una vez pues haya sido
nombrado el canciller alemán su primera
visita de estado la realiza a parís
ambos mandatarios entrevistaron
brevemente tuvieron un almuerzo de
trabajo y luego dieron unas breves
declaraciones también a la prensa
declaraciones en las que dijeron que
habían ha tocado gran parte de los temas
más importantes de la relación entre
ambos países y también pues los temas
digamos más candentes a nivel europeo en
cuanto a las preguntas de la prensa por
supuesto les preguntaron sobre la
situación
entre en la frontera entre ucrania y
rusia y ambos mandatarios pese a
explicaros que explicaron que ellos por
supuesto van a estar siempre del lado de
sus aliados en este caso de ucrania por
el respeto también de las fronteras
europeas y que están
dispuestos a continuar trabajando para
que se puedan apaciguar las tensiones en
esta región siguiendo el formato de
normandía ese formato que fue creado en
2014 y en el que tanto francia como
alemania pues funcionan como mediadores
entre rusia y ucrania ambos
ambos mandatarios también se dijeron que
saludaban y que felicitaban también las
iniciativas de joe biden el presidente
de eeuu quien esta semana también pues
se habló con el presidente putin al
respecto de lo que está sucediendo en
esa en ese lugar y también pues se les
preguntó acerca de ese boicot que se
está pues del boicot a los juegos
olímpicos en beijing de boicot
diplomático por ahora ambos dijeron que
lo que quieren es una respuesta
concertada no solamente de estos dos
países sino a nivel
aunque de manuel ma como calificó esto
de digamos que era un boicot o pequeño
pero sobre todo simbólico y por último
pues ya se les habló si en algún momento
se podría pensar en una respuesta diga
digamos un informe a nivel europeo en
cuanto a la crisis sanitaria además
sobre todo digamos en cuanto a las
diferentes medidas o por ejemplo como
los pases sanitarios y demás por ahora
ellos dijeron que se ha tratado de
trabajar de manera
cooperada de manera pues conjunta entre
todos los países pero no dijeron nada
digamos de que hubiera unas olas reglas
para todo el bloque
nicaragua rompió relaciones con taiwán a
de forma sorpresiva este jueves managua
mantenía buenos contactos con la isla
desde 1990 y taipei se había convertido
en el principal donante para nicaragua
en los últimos años así como un
importante socio comercial pero la
ruptura sea tan solo días después de que
las autoridades de managua condecorarán
al embajador de taiwán y le entregaran
las llaves de la ciudad más el informe
dejó resultado
un giro de 180 grados de forma
sorpresiva el gobierno de nicaragua
rompió relaciones diplomáticas con
taiwán uno de sus principales donantes
extranjeros y con quién hablar dio años
de buenas relaciones y cooperación
bilateral el gobierno de la república de
nicaragua
declara que reconoce que en el mundo
sólo existe una sola china'
la república popular china es el único
gobierno legítimo que representa a toda
china y taiwán es parte inalienable del
territorio chino según datos oficiales
tan solo en 2020 taiwán donó 28 millones
de dólares al sector público
nicaragüense
hasta ahora el país centroamericano era
uno de los 17 países del mundo que
reconocían a taiwán que es considerado
por china una provincia rebelde desde
mediados del siglo pasado
el gobierno de la república de nicaragua
rompe a partir de hoy las relaciones
diplomáticas con taiwán y deja de tener
cualquier contacto o relación oficial
pero minutos después del anuncio de
managua la televisión china difundió
imágenes de una delegación nicaragüense
liderada por dos hijos de daniel ortega
reunidos con autoridades chinas en una
ciudad cercana a beijing taiwán era
además un importante socio comercial en
los últimos meses las exportaciones de
nicaragua taiwán representaron más de 60
millones de dólares y unos 25 millones
en importaciones taiwán lamentó la
ruptura de relaciones diplomáticas con
nicaragua y catalogó como un desprecio a
los años de amistad el gobierno de
daniel ortega restablece las relaciones
con china cuando está aislado por la
comunidad internacional y distanciado de
la organización de estados americanos
oea que le exige la liberación de más de
150 presos políticos y cuestiona las
últimas elecciones presidenciales
nicaragua se suma ahora a países de la
región como panamá y el salvador que
rompieron con taiwán para alinearse con
la cooperación china
así las cosas chinas en nicaragua
entonces oficializaron sus relaciones
diplomáticas y el gobierno el gigante
asiático desde la bienvenida a la
decisión de nicaragua de restablecer
estos lazos taiwán por su parte dijo que
pese a la decisión de managua seguirá
defendiendo sus libertades
china da la bienvenida a la decisión
política de nicaragua de cortar
relaciones diplomáticas con taiwán y
reanudar las relaciones diplomáticas con
la república popular de china nicaragua
se convirtió así en el país número 181
en establecer relaciones diplomáticas
normales con china huawei se degüella
quinientas a howard en nicaragua son
esta mañana nuestro país y nicaragua
pusieron fin a las relaciones
diplomáticas creemos firmemente que no
importa si se trata de la represión a
través de la diplomacia o la amenaza de
la fuerza militar ninguno de éstos
cambiará nuestra determinación para
salvaguardar nuestras libertades
democráticas
lightweight saint sernin de javi y
julieta hoy 10 de diciembre se conmemora
el día internacional por los derechos
humanos y precisamente en esta fecha un
grupo de juristas y expertos en materia
reunidos en londres concluyó que el
trato que le da a china los uigures
equivale a un genocidio lo que enfureció
a beijing que lo denunció como una farsa
política basada en pruebas falsas
tras seis meses recolectar pruebas y
evaluar documentos el autodenominado
tribunal we would ha llegado un
veredicto
el tribunal está convencido más allá de
toda duda razonable que la república
popular china al imponer medidas para
reducir los nacimientos tenía la
intención de destruir una proporción
significativa de la población uigur en
xinjiang por tanto cometió un genocidio
fueron claros y directos para los nueve
miembros de este tribunal informal
conformado por juristas y especialistas
en derechos humanos los testimonios de
abortos y esterilizaciones forzadas
sumados a las condiciones de
encarcelamiento y tortura infringidas a
los we gures permiten hacer esta
calificación este tribunal con sede en
londres independiente del sistema
judicial británico se creó a petición de
los representantes de los exiliados
uigures desde el inicio de su labor
beijing no ha dejado de desacreditarla
en reacción al veredicto en un
comunicado de prensa volvió a hablar de
falsa política
el lunes fue el gobierno de la región
autónoma de xinjiang el que atacó
preventivamente y el llamado tribunal
hoy fue creado por una conspiración de
las fuerzas anti chinas de eeuu y
occidente y de grupos del turkestán
oriental como el congreso mundial uigur
funciona como una organización anti
china y terrorista y no tiene
credibilidad el tribunal o gurb espera a
urgir al gobierno británico a que
reconozca lo que considera es un
genocidio hasta ahora sólo la
administración estadounidense se ha
manifestado a favor de ello en francia
la asamblea nacional tiene previsto
debatir el 20 de enero un proyecto de
ley que reconoce el genocidio we would
la ministra francesa de pesca a nick jr
dirán advirtió que si los si londres ya
no concede hoy viernes por la noche
todas las licencias de pesca que le
reclama abrirá el procedimiento
contencioso previsto para el caso de
incumplimiento de los acuerdos del
preside la ministra precisó que en caso
de activarse el contencioso sería la
comisión europea la que lo va a dirigir
también que aplicaría las medidas de
represalia si son necesarias según
girard habana francia ha obtenido mil
cuatro licencias de pesca para pescar en
estas aguas bajo jurisdicción británica
y falta un 94
y camina hacia adelante la vacunación
obligatoria en alemania hoy el
parlamento aprobó la inoculación para el
personal de salud en este país europeo
aduciendo que quienes se cuiden de la
salud de pacientes en hospitales deben
tener un esquema completo que proteja a
todos estas fueron las declaraciones del
ministro de salud alemán dentro del
parlamento
estamos introduciendo la vacunación
obligatoria tal requisito es necesario
porque es inaceptable
completamente inaceptable que después de
dos años de pandemia las personas que
nos han confiado su cuidado estén
muriendo innecesariamente en los
hospitales porque personas no vacunadas
van a trabajar allí no podemos aceptarlo
wong efe.es no tenemos tiempo que perder
el objetivo número uno para nosotros es
proteger a la población en esta crisis
de salud sns de schütz la vacunación
obligatoria en europa ha entrado a
debate con el alza de los contagios y la
aparición de la variante omicron sin
embargo no existe un consenso entre los
ministros de sanidad europeos rodrigo se
da no nos tiene un resumen de la
situación
no hay consenso en europa sobre la
vacunación con la aparición de la
variante omicron ursula von der leyen
pidió abrir el debate de la vacunación
obligatoria
cómo podemos afrontar y pensar en una
potencial obligatoriedad de la
vacunación en la unión europea se
necesita una discusión esto necesita una
aproximación común pero es una discusión
que necesitamos afrontar ya su vez la
mayoría de ministros de salud de los
países comunitarios se han posicionado
en contra de la medida por el momento
solo en austria será obligatoria la
vacunación para mayores de 14 años a
partir del 1 de febrero una medida que
ha causado protestas en el país
aquí
y estoy aquí porque estoy en contra de
la vacunación obligatoria estoy a favor
de los derechos humanos y la violación
de los mismos debería parar que quienes
se nieguen a vacunarse podrán enfrentar
multas de hasta tres mil seiscientos
euros por su parte grecia multar a los
mayores de 60 años que no se vacunen a
partir del 15 de enero en otros países
tienen soluciones más ingeniosas
eslovaquia dará 300 euros a todos los
mayores de 60 que quieran vacunarse la
medida sin embargo causa escepticismo en
algunos ciudadanos toma nota que nada
son aquellos que no querían vacunarse
antes de los 300 euros tendrán la misma
opinión ahora no cambiarán la opinión de
la gente en otros países comunitarios-
la vacunación general obligatoria no
entra en los planes de sus respectivos
gobiernos entre ellos suecia dinamarca
portugal o españa en donde más del 80%
de la población cuenta con al menos una
dosis
todos periodistas recibieron hoy en los
los premios nobel de la paz se trata de
la filipina mar y arresta y el ruso
dmitri murátov ambos fueron notificados
del galardón en octubre de este año y
hoy recibieron el premio el galardón lo
recibe en reconocimiento de su lucha a
favor de la libertad de prensa que reza
ha dicho se encuentra amenazada la
periodista filipinas que fundara el
portal web rapper que se enfrenta a la
cárcel también por su ejercicio
profesional mientras que el ruso murátov
es redactor jefe del diario
independiente
nóvaya gazeta
y de esta manera finalizamos el
informativo de francés 24 yo me despido
de ustedes por este año feliz 2022 para
todos nos vemos el próximo año
[Música]